[Music]
there's no doubt this is a couple who
continue to break with royal tradition
starting their tour in the nyanko
township known as the murder capital of
South Africa the celebrations laid on by
people trying to tackle growing levels
of violence against women and children
an issue the Duke and Duchess jointly
addressed I want you to know that for me
I am here with you as a mother as a wife
as a woman as a woman of color and has
your sister Megan hasn't publicly talked
about her mixed-race heritage since
marrying into the royal family it is
part the reason they connect with a more
diverse and younger crowd but there was
a side of me anger they were never going
to see because of security fears and
people who share their beliefs that
future generations deserve better
opportunities
improve the house build a Spearman so
that is why education if we can donate
amounted as for our development project
for for building people to build houses
and whatever then the crime will and
that's where Harry and Megan can bring
global attention their marriage was
celebrated for making the monarchy more
diverse the Megan was obviously moved as
she heard from those persecuted during
the apartheid equality and acceptance
themes that promote throughout this
royal tour the annal Mills Sky News in
Cape Town